This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的心理治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）为你主持的《学得艰难》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士的陪伴下进行的。有多少男人随身携带盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，收听
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%
《The Hard Way》，可在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%
on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
可在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取自己的方式。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends trust me babe on the iHeart radio app apple podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts
我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart广播应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》
to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology welcome back everyone beautiful people hope we're all doing well and thanks for tuning into this episode you've read the title we're talking about the anxious mind anxiety in our 20s um a real psychological topic. I think we've kind of gone off the beaten track. We've been talking a lot about relationships and friendship and life changes recently, but we're going to jump into something a bit more clinical and a bit more biological for this week.
欢迎来到《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在20岁时面临的一些重大变化和转变以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回来，美好的人们，希望大家都过得很好，谢谢你们收听这一期的节目。你们已经看过标题了，我们今天讨论的是焦虑的心智——我们20岁时的焦虑，这是一个真正的心理学话题。我想我们最近有点偏离常规了。我们最近一直在讨论很多关于人际关系、友谊和生活变动的话题，但这一周我们要深入探讨一些更偏向临床和生物学的话题。
So let's not waste any time today. We're going to jump right into what we're discussing because she's a big episode and we have a lot of content to cover so that we as a collective, as an audience, as a listener, can understand anxiety and more generally the anxious mind. So, yeah, we are exploring every area of the psychology behind this topic today just in order to kind of get a good understanding of the landscape around anxiety and get to the bottom of why our brain can be really anxious at times. We're going to talk about anxiety and panic disorders, existential anxiety, social anxiety,
所以今天我们就不浪费时间了，我们要直接切入我们讨论的主题，因为这是一个重大单集，我们有很多内容需要涵盖，以便我们作为一个集体、作为听众、作为收听者，能够理解焦虑，以及更广泛的焦虑心智。所以，是的，今天我们正在探索与这个主题相关的心理学各个领域，只是为了很好地理解围绕焦虑的全貌，并弄清为什么我们的大脑有时会感到非常焦虑的根本原因。我们将讨论焦虑和惊恐障碍、存在主义焦虑、社交焦虑，
how we can calm our minds, the science of meditation. You know, it attracts almost religious and feverish support from those who practice it, but is it fact or fiction? And how does meditation actually affect anxiety from a physiological perspective? We're also going to talk about biofeedback and the brain-body loop between the mind and body surrounding worry and anxiety, but also how our overall physical health, is so much more important for our levels of stress and anxiety than we've probably been led to imagine or to believe in the past. So yes, like I said, absolutely jam-packed. As always,
我们如何平静心灵，以及冥想的科学。你知道，它吸引了几乎带有宗教狂热般的支持，来自那些练习它的人，但这究竟是事实还是虚构？从生理学的角度来看，冥想又是如何真正影响焦虑的？我们还将讨论生物反馈以及围绕担忧和焦虑的心灵与身体之间的大脑-身体循环，但同时也会讨论我们整体的身体健康，对于我们压力和焦虑水平的重要性，远比我们过去可能被引导去想象或相信的要重要得多。所以，正如我所说，内容绝对丰富爆满。像往常一样，
before we get into it, if you do enjoy this episode and if you're called to do so, please consider leaving a rating on Spotify or Apple Podcasts. This is what allows this show to grow and reach new people. And it's a lovely feeling to do so. to know people are enjoying the pod. So if you feel called to do so, thank you very much. It's just me here. So all the reinforcement and affirmation is greatly appreciated. So yeah, let's jump right in, shall we? So why is the anxious mind or anxiety something I thought we should discuss on this podcast, a podcast about our 20s? Where does anxiety kind of sit? Where is its place in this decade of our lives. Well, I feel like it's no secret to anyone, really, that anxiety is a pretty common
在我们深入探讨之前，如果你确实喜欢这一期节目，并且如果你愿意这样做，请考虑在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上留下评分。正是这一点让这个节目得以成长并触达新的人群。这样做也是一种美好的感觉，知道人们在享受这个播客。所以如果你觉得愿意这样做，非常感谢。这里只有我一个人，所以所有的鼓励和肯定都非常感激。所以，是的，让我们直接切入正题，好吗？那么，为什么焦虑的心智或焦虑是我认为我们应该在这个播客中讨论的事情，一个关于我们20多岁的播客？焦虑在其中处于什么位置？它在我们这个十年的生活中有怎样的地位？嗯，我觉得对任何人来说都不是什么秘密，焦虑其实是一个相当普遍的
experience, not just in our 20s, but an important caveat to that is that the vast majority of mental health disorders like anxiety disorder do emerge during, you know, early adolescence or, sorry, late adolescence or our early 20s. So if you are going to have an anxiety disorder as an adult in your 30s, in your 40s, there is about a 90% chance that you'll have had it in your 20s or in your late teens. Basically, you're not just going to develop an anxiety disorder as an adult. You're going to develop it when you're young and then it will carry through to later adulthood. And all this emerging research that's coming out suggests that this is because in adolescence and in our early 20s, it's the time when our brain is.
经历，不仅在我们20多岁时如此，但对此的一个重要警告是，绝大多数心理健康障碍（比如焦虑症）确实是在，你知道的，青春期早期出现，或者，抱歉，是青春期晚期或我们20岁出头时出现。所以如果你作为一个30多岁、40多岁的成年人将要患上焦虑症，那么大约有90%的概率你在20多岁或青少年晚期就已经患有了。基本上，你不会平白无故地在成年后才突然患上焦虑症。你会在年轻时患上它，然后它会延续到成年后期的生活。所有这些不断涌现的新研究表明，这是因为在青春期和20岁出头时，正是我们的大脑正在
changing to a great degree. We once thought, I guess, that our brain didn't really change much after early childhood. There used to be this kind of consensus that, you know, once we reach the age of 12, all the neurons, all the structures were there, all the lobes were developed. But what we've seen is that the brain continues to undergo really profound changes up until your mid-20s, 25, if you're a guy, listening to this, which I'm not sure if you are. I know. that population of my audience is pretty low, but there you go. If you're under the age of 25, you've still got some growing to do. And your brain is quite malleable at this time.
发生巨大改变的时期。我想，我们曾经以为大脑在幼儿期之后就不会有什么大变化了。过去曾有一种共识，即当我们长到12岁时，所有的神经元、所有的结构都已经具备，所有的脑叶都已经发育完全。但我们所看到的是，直到你二十岁中期——如果你是个男士的话，就是25岁——大脑一直在经历非常深远的变化，虽然我不太确定你是不是。我懂的，我听众中的这个群体比例相当低，但事实就是如此。如果你未满25岁，你还有一些成长空间。而且此时你的大脑相当具有可塑性。
So being exposed to different influences in your social and physical environment can really have a profound impact on the way that your brain is going to continue to develop and your experience with things like anxiety or even an anxiety disorder later in adulthood and into your late 20s. So anxiety means a few things as well. Let's just clarify what we're talking about here. There is a distinction that needs to be made and is often made in psychology between anxiety, which is a sensation, it's a feeling, and anxiety when we refer to it as a disorder. So an anxiety disorder is different from general feelings of anxiety that we're all going to get every now and again,
因此，接触到你社交和物理环境中的不同影响，确实会对你大脑未来继续发育的方式产生深远的影响，也会对你日后成年及二十岁后期经历诸如焦虑甚至焦虑症产生影响。所以焦虑也意味着一些事情。让我们先澄清一下我们在这里讨论的内容。心理学中需要在焦虑（它是一种感觉，是一种情绪）和我们称之为障碍的焦虑之间做出区分，并且经常做出这种区分。因此，焦虑症不同于我们所有人偶尔都会产生的一般性焦虑情绪，
which we're going to discuss more later on. But it's really important to understand that distinction. I think they're often used interchangeably, which is kind of emerging in those discussions of how do we refer to mental health disorders in a way that's appropriate. You know what I mean? That being like, oh my gosh, I have anxiety when you're really just feeling, you know, maybe a bit socially awkward versus someone who has like a long term really debilitating experience with frequent panic. It's the same with like discussions around phobias as well, being like, oh my God, I have a massive phobia of that. You probably don't. Maybe you do.
我们稍后会对此进行更多讨论。但理解这种区别真的非常重要。我认为它们经常被交替使用，这在关于我们如何以适当的方式提及心理健康障碍的讨论中逐渐显现出来。你知道我的意思吗？就像是，天哪，我有焦虑症，而你其实只是觉得，你知道的，可能有点社交尴尬，相比之下，那些长期经历频繁惊恐、真正使人衰弱的人来说是不同的。关于恐惧症的讨论也是如此，比如，天哪，我对那个有巨大的恐惧症。你可能并没有。也许你有。
But there is an important distinction between the feeling of anxiety and anxiety as a medical condition. But firstly, we're going to focus on anxiety, the specific feeling, in our 20s. So just to get the definitions out of the way, because I know that it helps structure these episodes a little bit more. Anxiety is your body's natural response to stress. It's a feeling of fear or apprehension about what's to come or what is in your environment. And it basically contains a series of physiological, so physical, and psychological feelings or symptoms that make you feel alert, often at a cost. Say, for example, you know, there's a social situation, you're feeling really out of place.
但在焦虑的感觉和作为一种医疗状况的焦虑之间，存在着重要的区别。但首先，我们将聚焦于在我们20多岁时焦虑这种具体的感觉。为了抛开这些定义，因为我知道这有助于使这些节目的结构更加清晰一点。焦虑是你身体对压力的自然反应。这是一种对未来或你环境中将要发生的事情的恐惧或忧虑感。它基本上包含了一系列生理（即身体上的）和心理上的感觉或症状，让你感到警觉，通常是有代价的。比方说，你知道的，有一个社交场合，你觉得非常格格不入，
some of those feelings and symptoms that come along with that might be increased alertness because your heart rate's gone up. You might feel like a little bit dizzy. You might feel like your thoughts are running around your head. Maybe your palms are sweating. Those are all kind of, they kind of flow off of that need, your brain's perceived need in that situation to be more alert because it's sensing a threat in the environment. Now, because anxiety emerged as a response to something dangerous in the environment, it is a very, very, has a very long history. I'm sure you know this of, you know, it came from a very instinctual need back when we were running around the plains of the savannah or whatever to allow us to survive. And now it's kind of warped into something else because we no longer have those threats.
伴随而来的某些感觉和症状可能是警觉性提高，因为你的心率加快了。你可能会觉得有点头晕。你可能会觉得你的思绪在脑海中飞转。也许你的手心在出汗。这些全都是，它们基本上源于那种需求——你的大脑在这种情况下感知到的需求——即需要更加警觉，因为它在环境中感知到了威胁。现在，由于焦虑作为对环境中危险事物的反应而出现，它非常非常具有非常悠久的历史。我确信你知道这一点，它源于一种非常本能的需求，早在我们在大草原平原或其他地方奔跑的年代，是为了让我们能够生存下来。而现在它已经演变成某种别的东西，因为我们不再面临那些威胁。
that's a wild animal or something immediately that's going to kill us. So it's become kind of no longer necessary to the extent that it used to be in our modern lives because it originally served as a trigger or a way for the body to push you to either fight, flee or freeze. So this is known as the fight or flight response. I'm sure you've heard about this. But let's just explain it just in case you only know it from kind of a very shallow perspective or just knowing that it exists. So the fight or flight response is your body's
也就是野生动物或其他马上会杀死我们的东西。所以在我们的现代生活中，它在某种程度上不再像以前那样必要了，因为它最初是作为一种触发器或身体推动你进行战斗、逃跑或僵住的方式而存在的。这就是所谓的战斗或逃避反应。我确信你听说过这个。但让我们来解释一下，以防你只是从一个非常浅显的角度了解它，或者仅仅知道它的存在。所以战斗或逃避反应就是你的身体
reaction to a threat or a stressor in the environment. This is how it works. So our brains have evolved for, you know, ages for years and years and years, decades, centuries, all those time periods, to be really good at ensuring our survival and to be really good at identifying things that may hurt us or may cause us harm or harm to our community. So when your brain notices something in the environment that could potentially be a threat, it encodes that. It basically integrates that or interprets it more liberally. So our brains, they want us to be more alert than less alert. So if there's something in your environment that's a little bit ambiguous that could potentially hurt you, your brain's going to pick that up. And depending on your current kind of mental state,
对环境中威胁或压力源的反应。它是这样运作的。因此，我们的大脑经过了无数年、多年、几十年、几个世纪以及所有这些时间段的进化，变得非常擅长确保我们的生存，并且非常擅长识别可能伤害我们或对我们及我们的社区造成伤害的事物。因此，当你的大脑注意到环境中可能存在威胁的事物时，它会将其编码。它基本上是以更宽松的方式整合或解释它。所以我们的大脑希望我们保持高度警惕而不是不够警惕。因此，如果你的环境中有一些模棱两可、有可能伤害到你的东西，你的大脑就会捕捉到它。并且根据你当前的精神状态，
either you process it and you, you know, disregard it, or you become attuned to it and you see it as something that, like, yeah, we should be worried about this. That sends a bunch of reactions through our body. It activates a part of our nervous system, so part of our, yeah, basically of our, like, central nervous system called the sympathetic nervous system. So the sympathetic nervous system is part of our central nervous system.
要么你处理它然后，你知道的，忽略它，要么你对它变得敏感，把它看作是一件像，是的，我们应该对此感到担忧的事情。这会在我们的身体中引发一系列反应。它激活了我们神经系统的一部分，也就是我们，是的，基本上是我们中枢神经系统的一部分，叫做交感神经系统。所以交感神经系统是我们中枢神经系统的一部分，
and it's the part that wants us to be active. It's the part that responds to stress. So when stimulated, the nerves that form part of the sympathetic nervous system, they prepare you to either flee or to fight. So fight or flight, that's the response, right? So the things that you'll probably feel are, maybe you won't be able to feel this particularly, but the nervous system, it increases blood flow to your muscles, It decreases blood flow to things that probably won't help you in that situation, like your digestive system, like your skin.
它也是那个希望我们保持活跃的部分。它是对压力做出反应的部分。因此，当受到刺激时，构成交感神经系统的神经会让你做好逃跑或战斗的准备。所以战斗或逃跑，这就是反应，对吧？所以你可能会感觉到的事情是，也许你无法特别清晰地感觉到这一点，但神经系统会增加流向肌肉的血液，它会减少流向那些在那种情况下可能对你没有帮助的东西的血液，比如你的消化系统，比如你的皮肤。
And it basically activates all these other things that result in, you know, that feeling of like being sweaty and being anxious and feeling jittery. And it also triggers the release of norapinephrine, which is our stress hormone, which pushes us to be able to run faster, to be able to stay still if we're, you know, hiding. to be able to fight back. It's what is known as adrenaline. Adrenaline is a key feature of that stress response of anxiety. So then, you know, you felt anxious. You've either, you know, fought off this threat. And now your brain needs to calm you down. You know, you can't, you know, your body can't always be in a heightened state of alert. And there comes the parasympathetic nervous system. So this is kind of the sister to the sympathetic nervous system, but it does the opposite of what the sympathetic nervous system does. It's kind of like an ice bath for the body. It releases another
它基本上会激活所有其他导致，你知道的，那种出汗、焦虑和心神不宁的感觉的生理机制。它还会触发去甲肾上腺素的释放，这是我们的压力荷尔蒙，它促使我们能够跑得更快，如果我们，你知道的，在躲藏时能够保持静止，能够进行反击。这就是所谓的肾上腺素。肾上腺素是压力反应和焦虑的一个关键特征。然后，你知道的，你感到了焦虑。你或者，你知道的，击退了这个威胁。现在你的大脑需要让你平静下来。你知道，你不能，你知道的，你的身体不可能总是处于高度戒备状态。副交感神经系统就此登场。所以这是交感神经系统的姐妹系统，但它做着与交感神经系统相反的事情。它有点像身体的冰浴。它释放另一个
set of chemicals to tell your body to kind of chill, to release tension in your muscles, to restart that blood flow to less important features of your body and of your systems in a fight, but which we kind of need for everyday use, like your digestion. digestive system and those things like that. So this chemical reaction is what causes anxiety. Now, like I said, back in the past, that was super useful. But in the modern day, we tend to be triggered by many things that aren't even dangerous anymore. That's where a lot of social anxiety comes from, you know, small things that our brains, you know,
组化学物质告诉你的身体要放松，释放肌肉中的紧张感，恢复流向那些在战斗中不太重要但我们在日常生活中需要的身体部位和系统的血液，比如你的消化系统以及诸如此类的东西。正是这种化学反应引起了焦虑。现在，就像我说的，在过去，这超级有用。但在现代，我们往往会被许多甚至不再危险的事物所触发。这就是很多社交焦虑的来源，你知道的，一些小事，我们的大脑，你知道的，
previously definitely did need to interpret as threats. But in the modern day, they really aren't that scary anymore. they're really not going to cause you severe harm or stress. So think about it like this. Think about you're walking down the street and you hear like a loud noise. You can feel really anxious about that, you know, despite the fact that it probably doesn't mean, you know, that a rival tribe is coming to get you or a dog,
以前绝对需要将其解释为威胁。但在现代，它们真的没有那么可怕了。它们真的不会对你造成严重的伤害或压力。所以可以这样想。想象一下你走在街上，你听到一个很大的声音。你可能会对此感到非常焦虑，你知道的，尽管事实是这可能并不意味着，你知道的，一个敌对的部落来抓你了或者有一只狗，
like a dog barks at you or like a shadowy figure in the night. But we can also be scared of things like meeting you people. or having to go and do new things. And that's kind of where social anxiety comes from, which we'll talk about later, but it's kind of like our normal systems for anxiety have been hijacked and warped by our current modern day setting. So what are the downsides of that? Well, the downsides of that is that a system that previously was really important for keeping
比如一只狗对你狂吠或者夜晚的一个阴影轮廓。但我们也会害怕诸如结识新朋友之类的事情。或者不得不去从事新的事情。这也就是社交焦虑的来源，我们稍后会讨论它，但这就好像我们正常的焦虑系统被我们当代的现代环境所劫持和扭曲了一样。那么这有什么坏处呢？好吧，坏处在于，一个以前对于保持
us safe now is no longer operable in the same way. So it malfunctions and it creates anxiety about things that you don't really need to be anxious of. Now, importantly, there are individual differences in whether you're more likely to experience anxiety or less likely. So this is called the threshold for stress. So different people have different thresholds. Imagine it like those carnival games you kind of see in movies where people like bring down a hammer and something like, something like flies up in the air and you hit a certain target. So some people, just a small bump of that hammer, just a small threat or sense of unease will create massive feelings of anxiety
我们安全至关重要的系统现在无法以相同的方式运作了。因此它发生了故障，并对那些你真的不需要感到焦虑的事情产生了焦虑。现在，重要的是，对于你是否更有可能经历焦虑或更不可能经历焦虑，存在个体差异。这被称为压力阈值。不同的人有不同的阈值。想象一下就像你在电影里看到的那种狂欢节游戏，人们用锤子砸下去，某种东西，某种东西飞到空中，然后你击中了一个特定的目标。所以对某些人来说，只要那把锤子轻轻一击，只要一点点威胁或不安感，就会产生巨大的焦虑感
because their threshold is lower. So our brain only needs to reach a certain point for it to activate the sympathetic nervous system. Whereas I'm sure you know a lot of people, I'm sure you have a friend in your life who nothing stresses them out. Nothing. There is really not. nothing that freaks them out, nothing that scares them, they don't really feel anxious. And that's because their threshold is a lot higher. It means they're not as anxious about certain things. They're very lucky those people. And it probably causes less problems for them in some ways.
因为他们的阈值较低。所以我们的大脑只需要达到某个特定点就会激活交感神经系统。然而我确信你认识很多人，我确信你的生活中有一个朋友，没有什么事能让他们感到压力。没有什么事。真的没有，没有什么能让他们抓狂，没有什么能吓到他们，他们其实不会感到焦虑。那是因为他们的阈值要高得多。这意味着他们对某些事情没有那么焦虑。那些人真的很幸运。在某些方面，这可能给他们带来的麻烦也更少。
Well, I would definitely assume. Now, here's the thing. Where you sit on that threshold scale, so whether you have a low threshold or a high threshold, high threshold being you're less likely to experience anxiety. It's not a permanent state. You know, someone born with a low threshold or a high threshold of anxiety isn't always going to sit at that point for the rest of their life. It is mediated and moderated by other lifestyle factors.
嗯，我绝对会这么认为。现在问题是这样的。你在那个阈值量表上的位置，也就是说你是低阈值还是高阈值，高阈值意味着你更不容易经历焦虑。这不是一个永久的状态。你知道，一个出生时焦虑阈值较低或较高的人，并不意味着他们的一生都会停留在那个水平。它会受到其他生活方式因素的调节和缓和。
Like whether you are just undergoing a period of, you know, intense stress at work, maybe you're going through a breakup, you haven't gotten enough sleep, illness, all of those kinds of things. But if you are at a low threshold for stress, so you feel anxiety more frequently, that can cause a lot of problems. A lot of problems for our body, a lot of problems for our brain, for our mental health, our social health, the full package. So when neuropinephrine and other stress hormones are frequently activated, they also activate in your brain this thing called cortisol. So cortisol is the long-term stress hormone. It sometimes helps you in those immediate fight or flight responses, but it's more so a chemical that's released to deal with long-term stressful situations.
比如你是否正经历一段时间的、你知道的、工作中的巨大压力，也许你正在经历失恋，睡眠不足，生病，所有这些事情。但是，如果你处于较低的压力阈值，也就是说你更频繁地感受到焦虑，这可能会导致很多问题。对我们的身体有很多问题，对我们的大脑、心理健康、社交健康、方方面面都有很多问题。所以当去甲肾上腺素和其他压力荷尔蒙被频繁激活时，它们也会在你大脑中激活一种叫做皮质醇的东西。所以皮质醇是长期压力荷尔蒙。它有时在那些即时的战斗或逃跑反应中对你有帮助，但它更多是一种为了应对长期压力情况而释放的化学物质。
That's great. It's really useful. It's really useful for keeping you alert, for keeping you focused, for keeping you active during periods of intense stress if they don't last for very long. But if you're frequently getting these bursts of cortisol in your brain and in your body, it will begin to build up and it triggers an immune response. So if your brain is repeatedly using that resource, it's taking away energy from your immune system. So that's why after periods of intense stress, you know, after you finish like exams or something like that,
这很好。它真的很有用。如果你经历的强烈压力持续时间不长，它对于让你保持警觉、保持专注、在压力期间保持活跃非常有用。但如果你经常在大脑和身体中爆发这种皮质醇，它就会开始积聚并引发免疫反应。所以如果你的大脑重复使用该资源，它就会夺走你免疫系统的一部分能量。这就是为什么在经历剧烈压力之后，你知道的，在考完试或类似的事情之后，
you see a lot of people get sick because our brains have been so focused on that stressful event and that stressful period that it's taken energy away from other areas of our body such as fighting off disease or fighting off parasites and moved it towards what we need in the moment. And cortisol really causes that because it puts a lot of strain and stress on our body. And if you have periods of increased cortisol or heightened cortisol levels for a long time, you're going to experience a range of consequences, not just getting sick more often, but long-term stress responses, things like burnout, explosions of, anger and rage because your body, whoops, that was my email, because your body cannot handle the
你会看到很多人生病，因为我们的大脑一直高度集中在那场压力事件和压力时期，以至于它夺走了我们身体其他区域的能量，比如抵御疾病或抵御寄生虫，并将其转移到我们当下所需的事情上。皮质醇确实会导致这种情况，因为它给我们的身体带来了很大的负担和压力。如果你长时间处于皮质醇增加或皮质醇水平升高的时期，你将会经历一系列后果，不仅仅是更频繁地生病，还有长期的压力反应，比如精疲力竭、愤怒和暴怒的爆发，因为你的身体，哎呀，那是我的电子邮件，因为你的身体无法承受
constant pressure on your systems and on the rest of your body. And for the example of this, if you're working a really stressful job as like an investment banker or as a healthcare worker, as an emergency response worker, you're likely to have periods of heightened cortisol for extended periods of time, or back-to-back periods of time. And that has other health consequences that are longer term than, you know, burnout or explosions. You might have a high risk of cardiac issues because it's putting that increase in blood pressure caused by those neurotransmitters and those chemicals are putting increased pressure on your heart. You might have more problems with your muscles because stress increases kind of the activation of your muscles, so they
系统和身体其他部位受到的持续压力。举个例子，如果你从事一份压力非常大的工作，比如投资银行家、医护人员、急救人员，你很可能会在很长一段时间内，或者连续一段时间内处于皮质醇升高的状态。这会带来比精疲力竭或情绪爆发更长期的健康后果。你可能会面临很高的心脏问题风险，因为由这些神经递质和化学物质引起的血压升高正在给你的心脏带来更大的压力。你的肌肉可能会出现更多问题，因为压力会增加肌肉的激活，所以它们
become increasingly under pressure and increasingly stress. So things like that. So anxiety as a reaction to an event or something external can be really stressful. And as we've talked about, over a long period of time, it can actually be quite dangerous. It can be dangerous to you. In our 20s, our experiences with anxiety and the sources of anxiety are going to be very different to where the source of that comes from in our teenage years. and later adulthood. So especially in our mid-20s, when, you know, we're probably finished with things like exams. We're finished with long-term study, which would probably cause a lot of stress in our teenage years. And we don't have those other commitments, you know, big financial commitments,
承受的压力越来越大，受到的冲击也越来越大。诸如此类的事情。因此，焦虑作为对某个事件或某种外部事物的反应，可能会带来极大的压力。正如我们所讨论的那样，在很长一段时间里，它实际上可能非常危险。它可能对你造成危险。在我们二十多岁的时候，我们对焦虑的体验以及焦虑的来源，将与我们的青少年时期以及成年后期焦虑来源有很大不同。特别是在我们二十多岁中期，当，你知道的，我们可能已经完成了考试之类的事情。我们完成了长期的学业，这在我们的青少年时期可能会造成很大的压力。而且我们没有其他承诺，你知道的，重大的财务承诺，
mortgages, children, marriages. It's kind of a pretty unique time. But there are also very big major milestones and transitions during this decade that are distinct and unique to our 20s. And further to that, there's a sense of novelty. We're going to be experiencing a lot of things for the first time that are going to become unique sources of stress and anxiety or be perceived as threats to our well-being by our body and by our mind and by our consciousness. So what are some of these unique experiences since I've hyped them up so much?
抵押贷款，孩子，婚姻。这算是一个相当特殊的时期。但在这个十年里，也有非常重大的人生里程碑和转变，它们是我们二十多岁独有且独特的。除此之外，还有一种新鲜感。我们将第一次体验许多事情，它们将成为独特的压力和焦虑来源，或者被我们的身体、大脑和意识视为对我们福祉的威胁。既然我对它们进行了如此大的炒作，那么这些独特的体验究竟有哪些呢？
Well, the first thing is big life transitions like going to university and moving out of home. That is a major stress. for a lot of people. You have to adapt to a new kind of educational system, new support structures, new daily routines, new way of doing things. And you probably no longer have, if you're lucky, that stable support of your family that you used to have when you lived at home. That's compounded by new financial responsibilities like rent and paying for your utilities and learning how to feed yourself consistently and get yourself places.
嗯，第一件事就是人生中的重大转变，比如上大学和搬离父母家。对许多人来说，这是一巨大的压力。你必须适应一种新的教育系统、新的支持结构、新的日常生活、新的做事方式。而且，如果你运气好的话，你可能不再拥有过去住在家里时那种来自家庭的稳定支持。雪上加霜的是新的经济责任，比如房租、支付水电费、学习如何持续地照顾好自己的饮食并去到自己想去的地方。
and kind of adapt to these new circumstances that you're in. And for all those who have done uni, who have started uni, that first year, it can be quite stressful as you try and find your place in that new environment and you try and live on your own. But it also relates to a second thing, which is things like new relationships and new friendships. Even if you didn't go to uni, which is just my vantage point, but in your 20s, you begin to perhaps shift away from previously held. groups of friends, your high school friends, your neighborhood friends, and you start forming more serious relationships and shifting social groups. This can cause a lot of things. It can cause
并且去适应你所处的这些新环境。对于所有上过大学、开始上大学的人来说，第一年可能会压力很大，因为你要试图在新环境中找到自己的位置，并努力独立生活。但这与第二件事也有关，那就是诸如新的恋爱关系和新的友谊之类的事情。即使你没有上大学——这只是我的视角——但在你二十多岁时，你可能开始逐渐远离以前的社交圈，你的高中朋友、邻居朋友，你开始建立更严肃的关系并改变社交圈。这可能会导致很多事情。它会导致
things like FOMO, fear of missing out, which I did a whole episode back when I first started the podcast about how, if you've never experienced FOMO before, if you've always felt really content with your friendships, it can be a really stressful experience. There are also unique challenges that come with creating more serious relationships and friendships, like conflict, like misunderstandings. You know, like I said, like breakups, like friendship breakups, which is another episode that we talked about. Relationships and friendships are a huge source of joy and pleasure and enjoyment, but they're also a huge source of stress when they're not going right.
比如FOMO（错失恐惧症）之类的事情。我刚开始做播客时曾专门做过一整期节目讨论这个：如果你从未经历过FOMO，如果你一直对自己的友谊感到非常满足，这可能会是一段压力很大的经历。建立更认真的恋爱关系和友谊也会带来独特的挑战，比如冲突、误解。你知道的，就像我说的，比如分手，比如朋友绝交，这是我们讨论过的另一期节目。恋爱和友谊是欢乐、愉悦和享受的巨大源泉，但当它们进展不顺利时，它们也是巨大的压力源。
because they are so important to our well-being, we place a lot of pressure and emphasis on them. There are other things. First jobs. Jobs working full-time? That is stressful. And as someone who's gone through that recently, starting my first kind of 9-to-5 experience, it completely shifts the dynamics of your day and of your routine and of your life, you know, having to get up and go to work every morning, get there by 9, finish by 5 or 6, figuring out how to structure your hobbies and the things that you love and getting outdoors and seeing your friends around this new reality for yourself. And then perhaps things that are more person to person like new sleeping habits, socializing,
因为它们对我们的福祉至关重要，我们对它们寄予了厚望并施加了很大压力。还有其他事情。第一份工作。全职工作？那压力太大了。作为一个最近刚经历过这一切、开始了我第一份朝九晚五经历的人，它彻底改变了你的一天、你的日常生活以及你生活的节奏，你知道的，每天早晨必须起床去上班，9点前赶到，5点或6点结束，还要弄清楚如何在围绕这个新现实的间隙安排你的爱好、你热爱的事物、去户外走走以及见朋友。然后也许是更具个人色彩的事情，比如新的睡眠习惯、社交、
partying, drugs, using, starting to drink alcohol. Alcohol is a massive source of stress and it can create stressful situations. and in our 20s is probably, you know, late teens, early 20s is when we start drinking and when we start socializing and partying and being responsible for our own actions in that way. And, you know, there are a lot of other things. And in addition to that as well, like I said, alcohol is a massive one. Not knowing your boundaries in your 20s, that's when you really start to create an expectation for your relationship and relationships and your friendships and for your family and for yourself.
派对、吸毒、开始喝酒。酒精是一个巨大的压力源，它会造成压力重重的局面。在我们二十多岁的时候，可能也就是十几岁末、二十岁出头，我们开始喝酒，开始社交、参加派对，并以这种方式为自己的行为负责。而且，你知道的，还有很多其他事情。除此之外，就像我说的，酒精是一个巨大的因素。在你二十多岁时不知道自己的界限，这正是你真正开始对你的恋爱关系、友谊、家庭以及你自己建立期望的时候。
about how you want to be treated and how you show respect to yourself and respect to others, what you do to take care of yourself and things like that. There's also the experience of really not knowing where you are in the world. Quintessential, early 20s, late 20s, all 20s experience. I think this decade is often defined by major shifts in how we choose to live our lives, lives, major shifts in our values, in our daily routines, and alongside that, there's this pressure to kind of know what you're doing, to try and get ahead and achieve your goals. And that puts a lot of pressure on us, a lot of pressure on us in this decade, because here's
关于你希望如何被对待，以及你如何尊重自己和尊重他人，你做些什么来照顾自己等等。还有一种体验，就是真的不知道自己在世界上处于什么位置。典型的二十多岁初、二十多岁末、整个二十多岁的体验。我认为这个十年往往由我们选择生活方式的重大转变、我们价值观的重大转变、我们的日常生活的重大转变所定义，伴随而来的是一种压力，要求你知道自己在做什么，努力奋进并实现你的目标。这给我们在这个十年里施加了很大的压力，给我们施加了沉重的压力，因为这里有一个
a secret. No one fucking knows. There is no playbook. And we can make a lot of mistakes, which cause stress. We can step out of line, do things we regret, be challenged by a lot of different situations. that we haven't yet been in, and if we have been, we've normally had the support of our family and close social circles that we no longer have. And this kind of relates to another point that I really like to discuss with my friends and with other people who are in this, you know,
秘密。根本没有人他妈的知道。根本没有所谓的行动指南。我们会犯很多错误，这会造成压力。我们会出格、做我们后悔的事、面临许多不同情况的挑战，这些情况是我们以前未曾经历过的，如果我们经历过，我们通常也会得到家庭和亲密社交圈的支持，而现在我们不再拥有这些了。这有点像另一个我真的很喜欢跟朋友以及其他处在这个，你知道的，
this age with me. And that's around career anxiety. Career anxiety is like huge for people our age, for millennials, I guess is what we're called. I don't really know. But people in our 20s, because there is this pressure in society to be hustling and working to be, you know, the next Steve Jobs or whatever, you know, Elon Musk, someone popular, I'm obviously not in tune with that entrepreneurial side, but there's this sense that we need to, yeah, have it all figured out but be working really hard and have an idea of what we're working hard for and where we want to be in 10 years. But it's always going to leave us feeling less than if we're working, we were, you know, just focus more on personal development.
和我一样年龄的人讨论的话题。那就是关于职业焦虑。对于我们这个年龄的人来说，职业焦虑简直太巨大了，对于千禧一代，我想我们是这样被称呼的。我其实不太清楚。但对于我们二十多岁的人来说，因为社会上存在一种压力，要求我们要拼搏、要工作，要成为下一个史蒂夫·乔布斯或别的什么人，你知道的，埃隆·马斯克，某个受欢迎的人，我显然不怎么了解创业那一面，但有一种感觉，就是我们需要，是的，把一切都搞清楚，但要非常努力地工作，并且对我们努力的目标以及10年后想去的地方有个概念。但如果我们把工作重点更多地放在个人发展上，它总是会让我们觉得自己不如别人。
Not to mention, like, it's just a bit of a race. It's all a bit of a rat race of trying to be the best and the most inventive and the most successful. And there is this internal and external pressure to have things figured out immediately after you finish your trade or after you finish high school or after you finish your first job or union to be constantly reinventing the wheel that is your life. It's really exhausting. And it creates a lot of anxiety because it's a sense of threat. We have all this apprehension about the future, about if things are going to be okay. And the wonderful thing is that, you know, most of the time they do turn out to be that way. But in the moment, in those really tense and tough periods, there's no way to guarantee that.
更不用说，这就像是一场竞赛。这一切都有点像一场试图成为最优秀、最具创造力和最成功的人的鼠目寸光的竞争。在完成你的职业培训、高中毕业、第一份工作或大学毕业后，有一种内在和外能的压力，要求你立刻把事情搞清楚，不断地重塑你的生活这个轮子。这真的很累人。它会产生很大的焦虑，因为它是一种威胁感。我们对未来充满担忧，担心一切是否会好起来。但美妙的是，你知道的，大多数时候事情确实会变成那样。但在当下，在那些高度紧张和艰难的时期，没有任何方法可以保证这一点。
And it links up to a lot of catastrophizing and a lot of unknowns that are a huge source of anxiety. I've heard it from so many friends, so many people I've talked to this about. And that alongside all those other shifts that we've talked about, what do we do about it? What do we do? If you're someone who has a low threshold for anxiety or who is prone to experiencing anxiety, perhaps more often than someone else, are there basic ways to kind of manage that feeling or are you just beholden to it? You don't have to wait very long for the answer.
这与大量的灾难化思维以及许多未知的、成为巨大焦虑之源的事情联系在一起。我从许多朋友、许多与我探讨过此事的人那里听到过这种说法。抛开我们讨论过的所有其他转变不谈，我们对此该做些什么？我们该怎么办？如果你是一个焦虑阈值较低、或者比其他人更容易经历焦虑的人，有没有什么基本的方法可以管理这种感觉，还是说你只能任由它摆布？你不需要等待太久就能得到答案。
There is definitely a way to manage feelings. of anxiety. And like I said, anxiety disorders a whole other can of worms, which we will crack open in a moment. But in terms of, you know, frequent feelings of just like apprehension and fear and worry, there are things that you can do to kind of make that better. Obviously, this isn't an exhaustive list. But just some things that I've done, friends have done, that I've heard about, researched. The first one being, and I will stick by this for as long as I live, cut out caffeine. If you are an anxious person, what are you doing? Why are you drinking three coffees a day?
绝对有一种方法可以管理这种感觉。焦虑。正如我所说，焦虑症是另一个完全不同的烂摊子，我们一会儿就会深入探讨。但就你经常感到的那种担忧、恐惧和忧虑而言，你可以做一些事情来改善这种情况。显然，这并不是一个详尽的清单。但这只是我做过、朋友做过、我听说过和研究过的一些事情。第一件事，只要我还活着，我就会坚持这一点：戒掉咖啡因。如果你是一个焦虑的人，你在干什么？你为什么一天喝三杯咖啡？
You don't need that. Your body doesn't need that. You already have enough of that alertness running around your bloodstream. So I was really anxious at the start of my third year of uni and I just decided to go cut a cold turkey on the caffeine. just stop drinking it altogether. And let me tell you, I've been converted. I think it was one of the best decisions I made for my mental health ever. It was great because caffeine is a stimulant.
你不需要那个。你的身体不需要那个。你的血液里已经有足够的这种让人保持清醒的物质在奔涌了。所以我在大学三年级刚开始的时候非常焦虑，我决定直接彻底戒掉咖啡因。就是完全停止饮用它。让我告诉你，我已经皈依了。我认为这是我为心理健康做出的最好的决定之一。这太棒了，因为咖啡因是一种兴奋剂。
It causes your brain to be hyperactive. It causes you to have a stress reaction. And some people can, you know, manage that fine. But if you are in a period of heightened stress and anxiety, there's just like no reason to be drinking caffeine. Your body's already pumped with enough stuff to keep you focused. and yeah, decaf's always an option if you like the taste. I drink decaf, I think it's fabulous.
它会导致你的大脑过度活跃。它会导致你产生压力反应。有些人可以，你知道的，很好地处理这个问题。但如果你正处于高度压力和焦虑的时期，根本没有理由喝咖啡因。你的身体已经充满了足够的物质来让你保持专注，并且，是的，如果你喜欢这种味道，无咖啡因咖啡总是可选的。我喝无咖啡因咖啡，我觉得它太棒了。
And when I stopped drinking caffeine, I remember there was like a period of two weeks where I was intensely tired, like intensely tired, could not focus because I was addicted. But after that like short period, it got so much better and now I don't think I've drunk, I'm like terrified of drinking caffeine. I haven't touched it for like two or three years.
当我停止喝咖啡因的时候，我记得大约有两个星期的时间，我感到非常疲惫，非常疲惫，由于上瘾而无法集中注意力。但在那段短暂的时期之后，情况好转了很多，现在我想我再也没有喝过咖啡因，我对喝咖啡因感到非常恐惧。我有两三年没碰过它了。
Caffeine is one. but perhaps a more broad idea is just removing stresses out of your life or facing them. So anxiety, a big source of it is avoidance, is realizing something triggers you or upsets you, and then avoiding it for the rest of your life. And all that's going to do is lead to more apprehension and an increased stress reaction or stress response, anxiety response when you do encounter that stimulus. Maybe it's like a friend you have conflict with. Maybe it's like a situation that you're really uncomfortable with, like giving presentations or driving long distances.
咖啡因是一个方面。但也许一个更广泛的想法是把压力源从你的生活中移除或者勇敢面对它们。所以焦虑，它的很大一部分来源是回避，是意识到某事触发了你或让你心烦意乱，然后你在余生中都选择回避它。而这能带来的全部结果，就是导致更多的忧虑，以及当你真正遭遇那个刺激物时，压力反应、焦虑反应会加剧。也许那是一个与你发生冲突的朋友。也许是一个让你感到非常不舒服的局势，比如做演讲或长途驾驶。
I don't know, whatever your cup of tears, whatever you're, yeah, whatever you're facing. But you need to either choose to remove that stressor if it's a toxic friend or a bad living environment. Yeah, you get to create the life you want. So get rid of those bad relationships. Get rid of those bad living situation. Those bad jobs. We've all had them. it's just not worth the time.
我不知道，随你的便，无论你面对的是什么，是的，无论你面对的是什么。但你需要做出选择，要么移除这个压力源，如果它是一个有毒的朋友或糟糕的生活环境。是的，你可以创造你想要的生活。所以摆脱那些糟糕的关系吧。摆脱那些糟糕的生活状况。那些糟糕的工作。我们都经历过这些。这根本不值得浪费时间。
And as we've talked about, there are long-term stress and health consequences to experiencing heightened periods of anxiety and cortisol release. You know, that's one option removing them. But like I also said, it's important to also face the stresses that you can't control, which are causing you anxiety, otherwise they begin to have power over you. It's all about having a sense of self-determination over your life, over what you choose to be beholden to what you choose to let you feel a certain way. There are other things as well, perhaps more practical, and I know I'm going to sound like a broken record, and if you've had
正如我们所讨论的，经历高度的焦虑和皮质醇释放会有长期的压力和健康后果。你知道，移除它们是一个选择。但正如我也说过的那样，同样重要的是去面对那些你无法控制、却正给你带来焦虑的压力，否则它们就会开始对你产生控制权。这一切都在于对你的生活、对你选择向谁妥协、对你选择让什么事情让你产生某种感觉，拥有自主权。还有其他事情，也许更切实可行，而且我知道我听起来会像一张破唱片，如果你已经
any experience with a therapist or a psychologist, I'm sure they have told you this again and again, so I'm so sorry. But meditation and mindfulness are so incredible. They are so incredible. They completely rewire your brain towards peace and towards being able to have a great biofeedback loop when you are experiencing anxiety. And I just really recommend it. It's really easy to do. Just download like a meditation app or go on Spotify where you're, I'm assuming, listening to this podcast. And you can find some incredible, incredible content to help you reduce feelings of anxiety, but also give you the resources. to deal with that feeling when it comes up in inappropriate times.
任何找过治疗师或心理学家的经历，我确信他们已经向你一遍又一遍地强调过这一点，所以我感到非常抱歉。但是冥想和正念真的是太不可思议了。它们真的是太不可思议了。它们完全重塑了你的大脑，使其走向平静，并且在当你体验到焦虑时，能够拥有极佳的生物反馈循环。我真的极力推荐它。它做起来真的很简单。只要下载一个像冥想这样的应用程序，或者去Spotify上，我假设你正是在那里收听这个播客。你可以找到一些不可思议的、非凡的内容来帮助你减少焦虑的情绪，同时也为你提供资源，来应对当这种情绪在不合时宜的时刻出现时的感觉。
And it's all part of this broader idea, I think, of healthier practices. You know, boundaries, caffeine, removing stresses, meditation, mindfulness. Those are all things that you can choose to do for yourself. And it comes hand in hand with other more practical things like physical exercise, which helps release stress from your body, getting a good night's sleep, taking care of your health. it's all part of a holistic response, I think, to making sure that you can operate at your best and you're not experiencing those negative feelings of worry that are perhaps getting in the way
这其实都属于我所认为的更健康的实践这一更广泛理念的一部分。你知道的，界限、咖啡因、消除压力、冥想、正念。这些都是你可以选择为自己去做的事情。它与其它更具实际意义的事情齐头并进，比如身体锻炼，这有助于释放你身体中的压力，获得充足的睡眠，照顾好你的健康。我认为，这都是全面应对措施的一部分，旨在确保你能够以最佳状态运作，并且你没有经历那些可能会妨碍你的担忧的负面情绪
of you doing what you want to do with your life. So far, we've spent a lot of time talking about anxiety, the feeling, and how to kind of get through that, why it is experienced. Perhaps more in our 20s in response to different things that are going on. But now we're going to jump into the second half of the episode, the encore, which is about anxiety disorders, a whole other can of fish, a whole another conversation to be had. So I'm going to make a disclaimer here. I'm obviously not an expert. I'm not here to diagnose anyone. If you think that you have an anxiety disorder based on what
阻碍你在生活中做你想做的事情。到目前为止，我们已经花了大量时间来讨论焦虑这种感觉，以及如何度过这种感觉，为什么会体验到它。或许在我们的20多岁时，面对各种不同的事情时体验得更多。但现在我们要进入节目的下半部分，也就是加场环节，内容是关于焦虑症的，这是完全不同的另一回事，是需要展开的另一场全新的对话。所以我在这里要作一个免责声明。我显然不是专家。我不是来诊断任何人的。如果你根据我们所讨论的内容认为自己患有焦虑症
we talk about, go and see your psychologist, go and see your GP. If you're in Australia, you can get on your mental health care plan. That's 10 free or subsidized sessions through your GP. And they'll help you find someone within your kind of area, within your area of, you know, not just geographically, but what you want to kind of deal with. And they'll help you out. So if you do worry or think that this might relate to you, just take a leap and go and get it sorted or think about, you know, the process that or the steps you can take to start doing the right thing for yourself and taking care of yourself. But like I said, anxiety disorders, they need to be diagnosed by, you know, more of a professional and clinical system, a feeling of anxiety, a feeling of worry. You can kind of identify that yourself. But when that feeling becomes prolonged, when you can't control it, that's when a medical professional would probably start to think that your system of anxiety, your sympathetic nervous system has probably started to malfunction and operate in a way. that's a bit dangerous or, you know, counter to your health. So anxiety disorders, there are a group of mental health problems that include things like
去看你的心理医生，去看你的全科医生。如果你在澳大利亚，你可以加入你的心理健康护理计划。那是通过你的全科医生提供的10次免费或补贴的咨询。他们会帮助你在你所在的地区找到合适的人选，不仅仅是地理上的，还包括你想解决的问题的类型，他们会为你提供帮助。所以，如果你确实感到担忧，或者认为这可能与你有关，那就勇敢地迈出一步去解决它，或者思考一下你可以采取的流程或步骤，开始为自己做正确的事情并照顾好自己。但就像我说的，焦虑症需要由更加专业和临床的系统来诊断，而焦虑的感觉、担忧的感觉，你可以自己进行识别。但当这种感觉变得持续不断、当你无法控制它时，医疗专业人员大概就会开始认为，你的焦虑系统，即你的交感神经系统可能已经开始出现故障，并以一种
generalized anxiety, social phobias, specific phobias, some of which you may have heard of, like agoraphobia and claustrophobia, and panic disorders. And bad news is that other issues like depression, they're often related to anxiety disorders. So these days, normally if you get a... diagnosis of an anxiety disorder, you're very likely to also have depression as a comorbid disorder alongside that, just because of the systems that they activate. So if you're up all the time and your body has to constantly be pushing you down and pushing your systems down, yeah, it's probably likely that you're also going to be feeling quite low and quite depressed. So anxiety disorders,
对你的健康有点危险或者说背道而驰的方式运作。所以焦虑症是一组心理健康问题，其中包括诸如
they're really common mental health problems that affect a lot of people. So I think estimates in Australia approximately 25% of the population will have an anxiety disorder that warrants treatment at some time in their life. And up to another 25% may also experience less severe anxieties around particular objects or situations like social situations or spiders or snakes or death or things like that. So one in four, that's a lot of people. That is a lot of people. And of course there's really no explanation as to why that's so high. Some people say it's because, you know, the modern world is created in a way that gives us such excess stimulation and additional things to stress about that these previous systems, which were more alert to very infrequent kind of threats and things in our environment and in our periphery. Now they're just like constantly activated by things going on in the world.
广泛性焦虑、社交恐惧症、特定恐惧症，其中一些你可能听说过，比如广场恐惧症、幽闭恐惧症以及恐慌症。而不好的消息是，像抑郁症这样的其他问题，它们通常与焦虑症相关。所以如今，通常如果你被诊断出患有焦虑症，你非常有可能同时也会患有抑郁症，作为伴发疾病与之并存，这仅仅是因为它们所激活的系统有关。所以如果你一直处于高度兴奋状态，你的身体不得不不断地将你压制下来、将你的系统压制下来，是的，你很可能也会感到情绪相当低落并且相当抑郁。因此，焦虑症，
everyone like I said experiences anxiety and fear at times they are normal and helpful human emotions and reactions that do help us deal with danger and can probably save your life however some people experience excessive and irrational a rational being a critical world there irrational anxiety and worries that become ongoing and distressing and that interfere with their daily life. Kind of hand in hand with anxiety disorders alongside depression is this idea of intrusive thoughts, which are worrying thoughts that just like kind of pop into your head and you can't do anything to stop them. All of these things, this frequent, distressing sense of worry, this is indicative of an anxiety disorder. And often there doesn't really appear to be an obvious or logical
它们是非常普遍的心理健康问题，影响着很多人。所以我认为澳大利亚的估计显示，大约25%的人口会在其一生中的某个时期患有需要治疗的焦虑症。另外有多达25%的人可能也会经历针对特定对象或情况的较轻微的焦虑，比如社交场合、蜘蛛、蛇、死亡或诸如此类的事情。所以四分之一，这是很多人。这真的是很多人。当然，对于为什么这个比例会这么高，实在是没有什么解释。有些人说这是因为现代社会创造了一种方式，给我们带来了过度的刺激以及需要去焦虑的额外事情，以至于这些以前的系统对我们环境和边缘中非常不频繁的威胁更加警觉。现在它们只是被世界上发生的事情不断地激活。
reason for the way that you might be feeling and that's what makes it kind of worse to the sufferer. It's really hard and researchers still struggle to understand why it is that some people develop anxiety disorders from general worry and some people don't. So these main features of an anxiety disorder are fears and thoughts that are chronic, so constant, and they're distressing. They're distressing. They're not a pleasant feeling and they will interfere with your daily living. Symptoms like panic or anxiety attacks or fear of these attacks in inappropriate situations, really intense physical reactions. actions like trembling and sweating, fainting, a rapid heartbreak, difficulty breathing, or nausea. And then finally, and this is one that I think a lot of people don't know in which we've kind of mentioned just before, but avoidance behavior.
正如我所说，每个人有时都会经历焦虑和恐惧，它们是正常且有益的人类情绪和反应，确实能帮助我们应对危险，甚至可能挽救你的生命。然而，有些人会经历过度的、非理性的——理性在这里是一个批判性的词——非理性的焦虑和担忧，这些担忧变得持续且令人痛苦，并干扰了他们的日常生活。与焦虑症以及抑郁症紧密相连的是侵入性想法的概念，这些是令人担忧的想法，它们就像那样突然闯入你的脑海，而你无能为力去阻止它们。所有这些事情，这种频繁的、令人痛苦的担忧感，都表明患有焦虑症。而且通常似乎并没有明显或符合逻辑的
Avoidance behavior is actually one of the key pillars of anxiety disorders. A person who's suffering from something like a social phobia or a specific phobia, they may go to extreme lengths to avoid a situation that they're not. they think could bring on anxiety or panic. And they're avoiding that specific trigger because of their fear of panic in uncomfortable situations, because of their fear of the sensation of anxiety. So let's just go through some of the types of anxiety disorders. We've got generalized anxiety. This is just like worrying about a lot of things like family, friends, health, work, money, all of those things for getting important things. And importantly, that anxiety,
痛苦的原因，而这正是让受痛苦折磨的人觉得更糟糕的地方。这真的很艰难，研究人员仍然难以理解为什么有些人会从普遍的担忧发展为焦虑症，而有些人则不会。因此，焦虑症的主要特征是慢性（即持续不断的）且令人痛苦的恐惧和想法。它们是令人痛苦的。它们绝不是一种愉快的感受，并且会干扰你的日常生活。诸如恐慌或焦虑发作的症状，或者在不合时宜的场合对这些发作的恐惧，非常强烈的身体反应，如颤抖和出汗、晕厥、心跳过速、呼吸困难或恶心。最后，我认为很多人并不知道这一点，我们在刚才也已经提到过了，那就是回避行为。
it can't just be like during a heightened period of like a week where you have a lot of deadlines. It does have to be present most days over a six month period. And, you know, I think sometimes when you're worried you can go for a run and sort it all out. But in the situation of generalized anxiety, you'll find it really difficult to control this feeling. Then we have phobias. So social phobias are the first one. They have their own unique definition in the DSM and what their own, you know, clinical set of criteria and characteristics. but a social phobia comes to people who are afraid of being negatively judged or evaluated by others.
回避行为实际上是焦虑症的关键支柱之一。一个遭受社交恐惧症或特定恐惧症等问题折磨的人，可能会采取极端措施来回避那些他们认为会引发焦虑或恐慌的情境。他们因为害怕在不舒服的情境下出现恐慌，因为害怕焦虑的感觉，从而回避那个特定的触发因素。那么让我们来过一遍某些类型的焦虑症。我们有广泛性焦虑。这就像是对许多事情感到担忧，比如家人、朋友、健康、工作、金钱、所有那些容易忘掉重要事情的事情。并且重要的是，这种焦虑，
They have an extreme fear of social acceptance of wanting to be included in the group that they have a membership to. And we've talked about the idea of social anxiety a lot on the podcast and how it is an incredibly natural reaction to want to be accepted. But a social phobia in particular leads to the fear of doing something that may humiliate you and in public or that may cause you to be outcast. And eventually, like I said, the avoidance factor comes in and you might avoid things like public speaking or eating or drinking in public or any social encounters like parties or the workplace because you're so worried about a negative social experience that might cause you to be kind of exiled.
它不能仅仅是在你有很多截止日期的压力极大的一周内出现。它必须在六个月的时间里的大多数日子里都存在。而且，你知道，我认为有时候当你焦虑时，你可以去跑跑步，把事情理清楚。但在广泛性焦虑的情况下，你会发现自己很难控制这种感觉。接下来我们有恐惧症。所以社交恐惧症是第一种。它们在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中有自己独特的定义，并且有自己的一套临床标准和特征，但社交恐惧症发生在那些害怕被他人负面评判或评估的人身上。
And some social phobia sufferers, they only feel one type of situation, whereas others may be concerned about several types of situation. And this can lead these people to avoid the feared situations, which is kind of a tragedy because it does create isolation and it does stop you from participating in the activities that you usually enjoy. So social phobia is its own. And then we have specific phobias. So a specific phobia, it's a persistent and irrational fear of a particular object or situation. So people with this may fear animals or places or people, really common ones are like dogs, blood, spiders, airplanes, and this fear is so severe that a person may experience physical symptoms and panic attacks and that anxiety becomes excessive and interfering.
他们对获得社会接纳、希望被自己所属的群体所包容有着极度的恐惧。我们在播客中多次讨论过社交焦虑的概念，以及渴望被接纳是多么自然的一种反应。但社交恐惧症尤其会导致人们害怕在公众面前做出可能会让自己蒙羞的事情，或者导致自己被驱逐。最终，正如我所说，回避因素开始起作用，你可能会回避诸如公众演讲、在公共场合吃东西或喝派对或职场等任何社交邂逅，因为你太担心可能会导致自己被某种程度上放逐的负面社交经历了。
Excessive and interfering unreasonable, those are the key words because you end up restricting your daily life because of fear of seeing these objects or experiencing these situations. And sometimes if you go to a psychologist or a psychiatrist, the way they get rid of this is kind of counterintuitive. In some ways, it is very logical, but they just like flood you with experiences. So if you've got a fear of planes, they make you build up and go on planes. Or if you have a fear of dogs, they'll like rapidly emerge you in a situation in which you're surrounded by dogs and you can't really do anything about it. But you're in a safe environment so that those close. consequences of what you think the dogs or the planes or the bloods is associated with, they don't come to be.
有些社交恐惧症患者只对某一种情境感到恐惧，而另一些人则可能对几种情境感到担忧。这可能会导致这些人回避令他们恐惧的情境，这可以说是一种悲剧，因为它确实会造成孤立，并且确实会阻止你参与那些你通常喜欢的活动。所以社交恐惧症有它自己的特点。然后我们还有特定恐惧症。所以特定恐惧症，它是对特定对象或因此，患有此症的人可能会害怕动物、地方或人，非常常见的有狗、血、蜘蛛、飞机，这种恐惧如此严重，以至于一个人可能会经历身体症状和恐慌发作，并且这种焦虑变得过分且具有干扰性。
So you learn to remove that association between the thing that you have a specific phobia of and the negative outcome that you've learned to associate with it. And amongst all of these things is the idea of panic attacks. Panic attack disorders though, they're a lot less common. They affect, I think, about like 1 to 2% of the population. And if you want to be diagnosed with the panic disorder, you usually have to have had at least four panic attacks each month over an extended period of time and these panic attacks, they have to come about spontaneously. Panic disorder, it might be diagnosed if panic attacks are frequent
过度的、具有干扰性的、不理智的，这些都是关键词，因为你最终会因为害怕看到这些物体或经历这些情况而限制你的日常生活。有时，如果你去看心理学家或精神科医生，他们摆脱这种情况的方法有点反直觉。在某些方面，这非常符合逻辑，但他们只是用各种经历来轰炸你。所以如果你害怕飞机，他们就会让你循序渐进地去坐飞机。或者如果你害怕狗，他们会迅速让你进入一个你周围都是狗而且你对此无能为力的情境中。但你身处一个安全的环境中，这样你认为狗、飞机或血所关联的那些可怕后果，就不会发生。
and if there is a strong and persistent fear of another attack occurring. And like with all of these, they are very separate from just the general feeling of anxiety and you need to go to a professional to have them diagnosed and there are heaps of different options after the fact for treatment. Things like medication really help people, meditation, cognitive behavioral therapy, immersion therapy, like with those phobias. And there'll probably be heaps of options and more options in the future about how do we actually help people with these disorders to overcome that debilitating sense of
所以你学会了消除你患有特定恐惧症的事物与你学会与之联系在一起的消极结果之间的联系。而在所有这些事情当中，还存在着恐慌发作的概念。不过，恐慌发作障碍要少见得多。我认为它们大约影响1%到2%的人口。如果你想被诊断为患有恐慌症，你通常必须在相当长的一段时间内，每个月至少发作四次恐慌，并且这些恐慌发作必须是自发产生的。恐慌症可能会被诊断，如果恐慌发作频繁
interruption in their life and live full and fulfilling lives. Well, I hope you've enjoyed this episode. If you're still here, congratulations, because it was a bit of a long one. But like I said, so much to talk about. There were so many things that I didn't include that I was like, this is so important. I should have included it. But maybe that just requires a part two. If you want me to go more into the science of things, I think I gave a bit of like a basic overview,
并且存在对再次发作的强烈而持久的恐惧。就像所有这些一样，它们与一般的焦虑感非常不同，你需要去找专业人士来诊断它们，而且在此之后有大量的不同治疗方案。诸如药物等事物确实能帮助人们，还有冥想、认知行为疗法、浸入式疗法（就像对待那些恐惧症一样）。未来可能会有成堆的选项以及更多选项，关于我们如何真正帮助患有这些障碍的人克服那种对生活的巨大干扰感，并过上充实而圆满的生活。好了，希望你喜欢这一集。如果你还在听，恭喜你，因为这一集有点长。但正如我所说，要聊的东西太多了。有太多东西我没有包含在内，我当时想，这太重要了。我本该把它包含进去的。但也许那只需要一个第二部分。如果你想让我更深入地探讨科学方面的内容，我想我给出的只是一点点基础概述，
but there's definitely a lot more depth. Maybe that's some area for your own research. But thank you again for listening. And I really hope you enjoyed it. I hope you learnt something as always. And if you have any suggestions for future ideas, I've got a couple of things that I really want to do. But I feel like I've been kind of taking the reins
但绝对还有更多的深度。也许那是供你自己研究的领域。但再次感谢你的收听。我真的希望你喜欢它。一如既往，我希望你学到了一些东西。如果你对未来的想法有什么建议，我有几个非常想做的事情。但我觉得我最近有点像是在
and just going a little bit wild and talking about a lot of random things recently. So if there is a specific topic, reach out. Let me know. Follow us on Instagram. Subscribe to us on Spotify. Just all those works. and thank you again for listening and if you're anxious right now
放飞自我，有点狂野，聊了很多随机的事情。所以如果有特定的主题，请联系我。让我知道。在Instagram上关注我们。在Spotify上订阅我们。只需做所有这些工作，再次感谢你的收听，如果你现在感到焦虑
go and see your GP please do it for me I promise it will help you and stop drinking caffeine that's the only thing you've learned from this episode anyhow thank you again and we'll see you next time hey what's good y'all you're listening to learn
去看你的全科医生，求求你为我这么做，我保证这会对你有所帮助，别再喝咖啡因了，这是你从这一集里学到的唯一的东西。无论如何，再次感谢，我们下次再见。嘿，你们好，你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人凯尔·盖恩斯主持的《艰难学习》
the hard way with your favorite therapist and host care games this space is about black men's experiences having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话除了和一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交谈外，在其他任何地方进行其实都不太安全。有多少男人穿着一套或多或礼服盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental tech. fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world.
在iHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理技术、体能和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他将得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。听女友们的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是由真人制作的。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可留下评论。